one of the interesting things was as
Raymond did this he said area I don't to
be approximate I would be actually equal
to right
he wrote this part that I might write
down next to wrote it down but he wasn't
sure how the mass was gonna pan out at
least at the beginning right he said
look I know what to do with this thing
right I just need to make n well I need
to take a limit write the limit as n
approaches infinity that's what I need
to do right and then I need to add up I
still need to do all of this I've got to
add up all of these all these little
rectangles they're still gonna have the
same height and they're still going to
have the same width but amazingly right
look at the width you see how it has an
inner right the width is dependent on n
what happens as n approaches infinity
this this thing he is going to approach
zero right it's important that it
approaches zero it doesn't usually get
them right in exactly the same way that
when we think about this guy
what's this a diagram of what's a truck
fine it's trying to find first
principles for the gradient at any
particular point now the important thing
is we're going to rise over run okay
there's your f of X plus h minus f of X
there's your H that's the run okay
we take the limit as H approaches zero
but like if H is actually zero I'm kind
of in trouble because I'm going to be
dividing by zero it never actually is
zero in the same way that this is never
actually infinity but I'm taking the
limit that's what this language allows
us to do to consider what if okay now
here's the amazing bit right up see you
can even kind of see on my diagram right
Riemann realized that he was doing
something fundamentally different from
here to here and then this thing okay he
said here I've got some that's what I'm
adding okay so he and some screw
mathematicians who took this and
developed it they called this thing here
this they called it a Riemann sum right
he was the guy who devised this idea of
adding up this bunch of rectangles some
finite number of rectangles to get an
approximate area okay but here when
Riemann's conceptually saw this thing
fell hold on this is no longer just a
sum or a bunch of things right because
there's an infinite number of the price
this is not behaving the same way
regular numbers do in fact this is not a
sum in the same way that these guys are
sums okay what I'm doing is I'm taking
all these little pieces and I'm actually
considering them as one whole right I'm
considering them as one piece that's the
only way you can do that okay now when
we talk about things that are one piece
we have a word for this right taking
many things and combining them the word
that we use that Riemann used is not
just a some fun an integral integration
when you integrate two things together
you are combining them into one whole
okay they're not just a bunch of
different parts anymore they're actually
one thing behaving together not like
this rectangular battery tape you can't
point two rectangles in this anymore
okay there's an infinite series of them
so this thing's behaves very differently
so because he thought one doing
something different here right
mathematically of doing something
different it was like you know this
Sigma notation it's not appropriate
anymore
simulation is about sequences of like
one two three four
you can't count this way with a shape
like this are you going affinity I'm
doing something different so he designed
you notations like no he's still wanted
this idea of Sun because conceptually
that's where this comes from
okay so instead of going to Greek he
just took a letter s and he stretched it
out okay so this is an S that's been
stretched out vertically okay now you
got to go from someone to someone I'm
going to talk about that in a second
okay but you said look these things here
right I've got a height I'm gonna call
that f of X it no longer makes sense
anymore to say XK like which one of
those torn up because I've got an
infinite series of them right I'm
considering all of them so I stop
thinking about the case I just think
about what wall of a final swim now this
next bit you still wanted this idea here
but now I don't have like I'm not
counting along I don't have like a value
of K there's an infinite number there so
I bet I can't really divide by infinity
it's not an actual number so you thought
how else could I describe this thing
right remember what it actually
signifies it's a width right and it's a
width importantly that is
infinitesimally thin hmm if only I had
some notation that talks about the width
of something that's infinitesimally thin
oh wait I already have this notation
it's already on the board when you go to
first principles right you're right f
dash x equals the limit H / - zero down
on it up but we stopped writing all of
that stuff because we say look this this
thing here the rise is a change in Y
right
the d stands for Delta
right this guy down here is a change
your next right like a tiny tiny little
change okay which is why we say rise
over run we write it as dy on DX just a
fancy abbreviated way of saying rise
over run well I just have a whole bunch
of tiny little run Yeah right
runs they're all DX's that's the actual
width that I'm dealing with and
infinitesimally thin with one last piece
Yeah right see from here our Sigma
notation right he adds from 1 to n that
makes sense because I'm adding up a
series okay you started the first time
you end up the last word okay but never
we transition into court in geometry
land like I'm actually not starting it
what I'm starting it the x value 0 right
and then I do go to and I actually end
at some particular value like - right so
these are these here no longer are about
1/2 n is about can be a sequence they're
about functions so you just need a
starting point and an ending point so we
called them a and B now this here right
this is an integral it's a way of saying
I'm integrating I'm putting together
combining this bunch of areas right
because that's the question I'm trying
to solve right I read this I read this
as the integral from A to B of f of X
with respect to X because that's another
way that we'd read this right
differentiate Y with respect to X it's
the same yes that is exactly right right
inferred in this notation is the very
principle that there's a limit going to
infinity so this thing here I said the
area equals right integral from A to B
all right so a V R where I start and
where I ends ok
in fact right now it was student
opportunities
to tell you these also have a special
name they're called bounce you've got
our lower bound which is where you start
just like how Sigma notation starts from
this lower number and then you have an
upper bound that's where you finish okay
so the area is equal to the integral
from A to B of f of X that's the thing
that I'm trying to work out the area
underneath with respect to X right DX
that's what it means okay we were
talking about on about like well what
other kind of areas on it it's off quite
a few okay but suffice to say this is
notation introduced to solve this
anterior of area